[Music]
get out of my contract this believe mark
my words not doing Jenelle Evans
threatening to quit Teen Mom 2 after a
string of controversies
I have people offering me stuff for
Netflix and Amazon right now the 26 year
old unleashed on her producers after
they asked if it was strange to film the
show without her husband David Eason
David's here okay we gotta cut you
MTV cut ties with David after a posted
offensive comments online earlier this
year the network still followed Janelle
who now finds herself in trouble with
some viewers after seemingly pulling a
gun on another driver during a road rage
incident seen on the show all while her
son was in the car with her Janelle
later denied it doing that though no I
didn't chase gun out on I did not do
that
Jenelle's mom Barbara who has custody of
Janelle's eldest son announced she would
seek custody of Janelle's other two kids
after learning of the confrontation holy
crap we got to get these kids out of
that house because this is too bad this
is bad I got a call in to my attorney
and we're going to go to court
[Music]
[Applause]